[Musique]
nous on sait pas quel jour soit tu es tu
y vas te tuer qui va kidnapper nos
enfants qui va tuer nos parents parce
que on a travaillé avec l'armée
française
c'est vrai qu'ils sont considérés là bas
comme des traîtres ils sont grillés ils
ont tout lâché de leur côté sinon le
retarde pas la main qu'est ce qu'il dit
est ce qu'ils deviennent
900 n'est pas là pour leur faire du mal
on est en patrouille
aujourd'hui on a des collègues qui sont
tous monassier par les talibans et d'al
arish à cause de leur collaboration avec
l'armée française traducteurs ont risqué
leur vie aux côtés de soldats français
avoir parfois ont permis de sauver la
vie de soldats français
il ya une volonté d'en rapatrier moins
possible parce que considère ces
auxiliaires d'armé comme des migrants
aujourd'hui qu'on les laisse derrière
nous c'est scandaleux oui c'est un
scandale d'état
[Musique]
à partir de fin 2001 jusqu'à fin 2012 la
france intervient en afghanistan pour
combattre les talibans et lutter contre
le terrorisme aux côtés d'une coalition
internationale
pour cette mission les militaires
français ont travaillé avec plus de 800
tard jinman des traducteurs afghans qui
ont toujours voulu être rapatrié au même
titre que l'armée française
j'étais encore à l'école que j'ai
commencé à travailler avec l'armée
française en 2003 jusqu'en juillet 2012
j'étais avec un équipe qui s'appelait
arctique
c'était un équipe d'intervention sur les
attentats exclusive c'était un équipe
d'investigation
j'ai donné mon au front pour l'armée
française
je travaille le jour et la nuit pour
l'armée française et travail avait des
trous étrangers
c'est toujours un risque les gens ici
pense que les gens qu'ils ont travaillé
avec la remise étrange ils ont des des
espions ma vie c'est complètement dans
en danger je peux pas les douars les
gens ils cherchent les interprètes
[Musique]
talibans n'ont pas hésité à exécuter des
membres de familles des traducteurs et
des traducteurs pour essayer de
dissuader les gens de venir le faire et
donc tous les gens qui m'ont été
traducteur l'ont fait au péril de leurs
vies au péril de la vie de leur famille
à et depuis le départ de l'armée
française en 2012 beaucoup de ces
traducteurs ont essayé de se cacher et
ils sont toujours vulnérables certains
d'entre eux se retrouvent régulièrement
reconnue voie des menaces
sur la porte de leur maison et certains
d'entre eux ont déjà été tués le 23 juin
le nuit à 23h15 j'étais attaqué par les
gens armés il y avait deux ou trois
personnes qui étaient armés
la porte et frappe mais je suis allé là
bas pour voir qu'ils les gens ils
parlaient entre eux que c'est sa maison
ils ont commencé 2-1 détruit la porte
d'entrée de chez moi
quelques vitres étaient cassées mais
heureusement j'étais pas touchés est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment d'avoir été
abandonné par l'armée française et
l'état français
oui je sens qu'on ait abandonné depuis
longtemps de départ des français
on est passé dans un situation très très
deux jours bien sûr que j'ai peur pour
la vie de moi et ma famille parce que je
vois je vous pas que je perde la vie de
mes enfants et ma famille à cause d'eux
que j'ai travaillé avec l'armée
française
le procès dure de delray des visas pour
les interprètes une fois j'ai demandé
mais elles sont raison ma demande a été
rejetée par l'ambassade de france ont
des optimistes on espère que bientôt on
pourra voir notre visa et sauver notre
vie la vie de nos enfants et la famille
[Musique]
les français sont arrivés en essonne
avait aucun relais locaux il connaissait
pas ce pays connaissait pas les vallées
de ce pays connaissait pas les coutumes
et connaissait pas la culture
donc il a fallu pour les militaires
français être en contact avec des
afghans avec des locaux et les relais
des militaires français s'était alors
leur interprète donc sans eux les
militaires français n'était rien en
afghanistan du coup j'ai voulu savoir si
des militaires français ayant servi en
afghanistan ayant travaillé avec des
traducteurs locaux trouvez ça normal et
c'est comme ça que j'ai rencontré
l'adjudant chef jean françois bon je
suis retraité maintenant j'ai été
instructeur de tir et instructeur
armements
j'ai été déployés en afghanistan je suis
arrivé en mai 2011 on devait former soit
des soldats sur des cadres dans notre
mission était aidé par des traducteurs
les cartes chez man
non ce n'est pas là pour leur faire du
mal on est en patrouille sur place ils
peuvent apaiser des tensions puisqu'ils
vont ils vont aller au devant des
populations expliqué ce que font les
militaires ce que fait la force ici ils
ont un rôle important c'est vraiment
l'interface est ce que vous les
considérer comme des frères d'armes
quand vous êtes en opération bah tout à
fait c'est pas pour moi c'était comme
comme des soldats au moins il était dans
mon équipe c'était comme soldats ou un
des frères da moins bien sûr il ya des
secteurs d'ailleurs où c'était dangereux
ils étaient armés
[Musique]
on sait qu'ils sont dans la vallée peut
pas dire le contraire fois ce qu'il
faisait c'était pour les renseignements
français de lait coûte
non il n'y en a pas ici c'est à dire que
ce sont des gens qui sont responsables
de la mort de militants talibans et que
les talibans n'hésiteront pas à exécuter
comme traîtres comme responsable de la
mort de certains de leurs combattants
donc ce sont des gens qui sont
aujourd'hui dans une très très grande
vulnérabilité
c'est vrai qu'ils sont considérés là bas
comme des traîtres ils sont grillés quoi
ils ont tout lâché de leur côté sinon
leur teint pâle amant qu'est ce qui dit
qu'est ce qu'ils deviennent et après six
mois d'opération sur le terrain
l'adjudant chef jean françois se lie
d'amitié avec son traducteur arif ou là
mais la france décide de quitter le pays
la france se retire il ya un premier
groupe qui a rapatrié
donc je pensais que tout naturellement
ça allait suivre surtout le cas de arik
et est francophile comme lui et puis
plus rien c'est là qu'on commence à
s'inquiéter
d'ailleurs chaque fois qu'il y avait un
attentat j'appelais
on a gardé contact avec skype voilà mon
âge été voir à droite à gauche mais
c'est d'intervenir avec mes petits
moyens et fils amaury l'arrivée en 2018
revenus s'étaient souvenus ce que
j'avais liger étude d'impact importe
quand tu récupères et c'était une [ __ ]
de bonne nouvelle ouais je sais pas je
me suis intéressé à harry peut-être
j'ai fais une fixette sur lui ou je vous
mettais toi tu boire un coup en
bourgogne
[Musique]
ça fait peur ils sont des faire venir
des argots en france alors que c'était
des gens qui ont travaillé avec des
français contre avec l'armée en plus une
certaine culture
je croise un juste injuste c'est donnant
donnant lui il a donné pour la france il
faut qu'ils reçoivent la trahison qui
est fait à ses traducteurs avenant est
d'autant plus forte que lorsque ces
traducteurs se sont engagés aux côtés
des militaires français il leur a été
dit qu'en cas de problème ils pourraient
venir en france ça a été une des
manières utilisée pour inciter des gens
à venir être traducteur être guide
il ya ici une politique d'état qui
trahissent des gens qui se sont battus
pour lui sauf que cette promesse elle
n'était pas écrite noir sur blanc dans
le contrat des traducteurs et lorsque la
france commence à se retirer de
l'afghanistan à partir de fin 2011
plusieurs centaines de traducteur afghan
ont fait une demande de visa qu'ils
n'ont pas obtenu parce que le ministère
de l'intérieur a décidé de mettre en
place des quotas très strictes nous on a
découvert que manuel valls à l'époque
ministre de l'intérieur dit nous on aura
patrie 35 sur les 800 qu'on a embouché
vous choisissez les 35 meilleurs ceux
qui présenteront le moins de problèmes
d'intégration en france et ceux qui sont
le plus en danger voulait rapatrier et
au cours de cette enquête les
journalistes quant à müller et brice ans
de lower découvre aussi des échanges de
mails entre l'attaché de défense de
l'ambassade de france à kaboul et ses
collègues où on peut voir en fait que
les traducteurs ont été classés avec des
appréciations tels que plus de 60 ans
familles nombreuses ou encore semble
bien islamistes il ya une volonté d'en
rapatrier le moins possible parce qu'on
considère ces auxiliaires d'armé comme
des migrants comme des chiffres en moins
sur le budget du ministère du logement
sur le budget mystère la défense donc il
ya un mépris pour ces gens là pourtant
en 2012
jean yves le drian alors ministre de la
défense est aujourd'hui ministre des
affaires étrangères assuré que la france
aiderait les traducteur afghan
la france ne doit pas abandonner ses
collaborateurs quelle que soit leur
situation et ceux qui sont le plus à
risque trouveront en france ou de
l'accueil qu'il mérite
bassett ans plus tard l'accueil de
certains traducteur afghan est en
réalité loin d'être à la hauteur
sur twitter un supporter du fc nantes
m'a parlé des safaris une famille de
traducteur afghan arrivé en juillet 2019
et qui depuis est baladés d'hôtels 115
en hôtel 115 je viens d'arriver à la
gare de saint nazaire où je rejoins
frédéric c'est un gap twitter qui a aidé
la famille qatari quand il a appris
qu'elle devait quitter son hôtel 115 90
et qui les a aidé à s'installer à saint
nazaire sur la veille mais entend
comment tu te retrouves en fait à l'idée
la famille sa taille
en fait j'ai découvert leur histoire au
travers du réseau social twitter et leur
histoire m'a touché et en plus ça se
passe dans ma ville donc difficile de
détourner les yeux quand on rit on lit
un récit est une histoire pareille
j'ai un compte qui qui regroupe une
communauté de fans nantes 1 entre autres
à ces importantes donc des gens qui
habitent nantes sous un hashtag qu'on
utilise qu'un hashtag on et nantes
[ __ ] ça veut dire qu'on
face à l'adversité on peut tout faire
quoi on peut on peut renverser tous les
tous les défis donc là on est arrivé
c'est internet à l'automne
voilà
au menu du mouvement one two three est
forte pourtant ils n'ont ni three months
nm à 6000 en france ali vakili expect
hectares de friches parmida des chutes
au cameroun tlf aura ce week-end en
france
because we have done a lot of words
words in semper ghetto quais de seine
fight position et nos sauts à des fils
de cu et bissau du théâtre avec my wife
décoché qu'un autre mouffe lycosa juste
par leicester avec michael dunn a
défendu lundi
fébrile en défense l'anglais y ait un
gadget witty une des choses les plus
difficiles pour la famille c'est l'ennui
il reste toute la journée mais en
chambre n'ont rien à faire ils n'ont pas
d'activité pas de cours de français donc
il n'y a vraiment aucune prise en charge
pour les aider à mieux s'intégrer ou à
reprendre le cours d'une vie normale
et s'il n'y avait pas les bénévoles pour
leur filer un coup de main il serait
complètement livrés à eux mêmes
le seigneur losilla soda club bac à des
faux pas yes we lose ils s'intéressent
ils adorent le football c'est ça le fera
pas la wiimote ou trois matches tout
d'abord au stadium et ne permettent pas
d'avoir ma chaise
qu est ce qui t elle fut surprise
aujourd'hui dans ce qu'ils ont ils
raconté
je ne sais pas vus depuis trois quatre
jours c'est de voir la meilleure mine
ils ont bonne mine quoi c'est je pense
que ils ont ils ont retrouvé de l'espoir
je pense que ça y est la rencontre entre
ces gens et puis la france ça y est les
fêtes et c'est ça qui je pense nous
importait avec les copains c'était de
leur montrer que la france s'était
c'était autre chose qu'une miteuse
chambre d'hôtel à lait maternisé
d'accord la folie comme monsieur 500
depuis 2012 la france en a accueilli
environ 250
elle fait figure de mauvaise élève à
l'échelle européenne à titre de
comparaison l'allemagne en a rapatrié
si ce reportage a intéressé vous pouvez
aussi regarder le documentaire que j'ai
réalisé sur la guerre en afghanistan en
cliquant juste ici et n'oubliez pas de
vous abonner à la chaîne youtube de brut
a très vite